- It's called the modesty rule
and basically they were saying you're--
which I find funny because
it's a school issued swimsuit.
It's not like she was like,
I'm wearing this from home.
Like they gave it to
her, to do the meet in
and then they punished you for it!
I would be so mad.
- Yeah I was so mad I--
- But you brought it up
and then you ended up telling
everybody about it right?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Go ahead and tell
your part of the story.
- So I'm head coach of a
different program in town
and our meet ended and
I got back to my phone
and it had just blown
up with texts and emails
to say this swimmer got disqualified
at another meet in town.
She's in a team-suit, approved
by the school district
and I said that's not okay.
If we don't do something
really extreme about this
then it's never gonna end.
- Because any girl with a behind,
like you know like mine,
like I'm just saying
girl with like a booty
like that's gonna ride
when you're being athletic
and you're moving around, it's gonna move.
It does the same thing with men.
- Yeah.
- Like I--
- Is there a modesty's
rule for men in this sport?
- [Coach] No!
- Because it just
seems like there's always
so much more scrutiny
placed on women than on men.
It just completely--
- When Brandy takes
her shirt off and
everybody's talking about it,
but guys can do it and it's nothing.
- Well it's like you
didn't take your shirt off,
you weren't in New
Orleans, you were covered!
Like you weren't trying to earn beads
like you were covered.
Like that's what I'm saying
so that's what my thing is.
I mean right!
- [All] Oh come on!
- That dude is in a banana
hammock on national television!
(laughing)
And you're telling me that's all right
but like her, I mean you
can't help it it's there!
I'm so mad today.
(laughing)
I am!
No but so what was
your, we heard that they
kind of are deciding to maybe
overturn this modesty rule
for the women right?
Like by the end of the year?
- So between the blog post going viral
and them having that on
their desk sitting down
to make a choice about it,
it took them less than 24
hours to return her victory.
- [Lady In red] Good.
(cheering)
- Yeah.
- I mean I know those 24 hours probably
really stunk for you because
you worked really hard
and you just didn't know why.
But god it's amazing that they did turn it
around that quickly,
- It was fast.
usually it's a lot longer.
- So is the rule changed?
- It is suspended, pending review.
- Oh come on.
- What's the rule?
- Technically what is the rule?
Go to that board meeting!
(laughing)
- The rule in the rule book states that
you gotta wear a suit that
covers the important parts.
Now the rule kinda sets
everybody up to fail
because it doesn't specify how much of
the important stuff needs to be covered.
- Oh okay.
- They should probably
look at that anyway.
But, ya know.
- And no one's looking
at that at a swimming
- Nobody's looking at that
- And if you are
you're a creep.z
- She's swimming!
You're actually a creep
- She's competing!
- if you're looking at that.
(audience applauding)
- Like leave her alone.
- Whatever!